now everybody knows the russians like
the chinese they're masters of
propaganda they used to use it to
control their people by controlling the
information flow
yet sadly in the united states our
current leadership releases its own
share of propaganda on a regular basis
consider their framing of the much
anticipated talks between chinese and
u.s officials in rome that just wrapped
now the focus was china's role in
backstopping russia and ukraine what
could be done next
the word the biden team wants you to
remember is intense
as in biden's national security advisor
had an intense meeting with a top
chinese diplomat
it was an intense seven-hour session
reflecting the gravity of the moment and
it was an opportunity to be very clear
about what you've heard our national
security advisor convey publicly but
more directly about what the
consequences would be
now a senior administration official
told cnbc that jake sullivan conveyed to
china's top diplomat yang chichi that
the u.s is concerned that beijing may
attempt to help russia blunt global
sanctions he was direct and those about
those concerns and the potential
implications and consequences of certain
actions the official added
translation
sullivan got nothing
and china yawned
here's how china saw the meeting chinese
president xi jinping has proposed mutual
respect peaceful coexistence and win-win
cooperation as the three principles in
developing china-u.s relations in the
new era
u.s president joe biden responded
positively with such important
commitments as that the u.s does not
seek a new cold war or to change china's
system nor will it oppose china through
strengthening alliances support taiwan
independence or seek confrontation with
china
china then referenced ukraine at the end
of this as an afterthought
now in washington
when a high-level meeting fizzles and
yields no deliverables as they call them
you send a spokesman out to spin the
atmospherics
and over at the state department
it was more words signifying nothing now
listen for the passive verbs connoting
america as an observer
we are watching very closely uh the
extent to which the prc or or any other
country for that matter provides any
form of support any such support from
anywhere in the world
would be of great concern to us this is
naked aggression
this is a war of choice
this is
a country
a
one individual at the top of that
country
violating
in a brazen manner
what have been the cardinal rules of the
international order for the past
70 years
okay first russia doesn't care about our
watching what's happening they care
about what we're doing
and right now we're doing nothing but
making china richer by the day uh nearly
what 50 billion dollars worth of goods
we buy from them each month russia's
watching that too second why are we
acting as if there's any question about
whether china is even helping russia
even if they're not selling weapons
directly to russia china is giving them
crucial help by buying their
agricultural products and of course
their oil
so this is a total end run around
western sanctions we've been saying this
now for what two plus weeks
and third as i've said for years
china does not care about the rules of
the international community neither does
russia
so invoking them very
piously doesn't get you anywhere it
doesn't get you any respect
now this was as far as the state
department got when it came to
accountability for putin's bankers in
beijing
we have
been very clear
both privately with beijing publicly
with beijing
that there would be consequences we will
not allow any country to compensate
russia there is a lot for them to
explain
okay nice try but none of these threats
add up to anything other than a huge
bluff
the real power brokers in the
administration aren't on board with this
china has the highest paid lobbyist
inside the beltway and they know that
john kerry he's the guy who really
counts here he puts climate change ahead
of every other issue facing america
and they know that kerry is desperate
for china's help on the issue as stupid
as that is
now the ccp also knows that it has a
friend in biden treasury secretary janet
yellen who has said that trump's trump's
old china tariffs are contributing to
inflation now
well this is great news for china which
of course wants them drop the
tariffs and of course china also knows
that joe biden himself whose son got
wealthy for dubious work in china has
said that china's growth is not a threat
to the united states
china is going to eat our lunch
come on man they're not bad folks folks
but guess what
they're not a cut they're not
competition for us
now what are the actual chances that the
feeble-minded biden is going to stand up
to john kerry janet yellen the myriad of
business and financial interest doing
china's bidding
now what about the odds he'll take on
the media establishment that loves and
protects china 24 7.
the answer
zero no chance
and understanding how xi views the
united states at this point is also
critical in any interaction or crisis
dealing with china
now right now xi sees us as a power in
decline
he sees us as weak and self-loathing a
country that is culturally depraved and
politically divided
but he sees his communist system as
superior in every way he's a nationalist
and he's aiming for nothing short of
global domination
and to get there his priorities range
from the substantive the belt and road
initiative type stuff to the frivolous
like his banning effeminate male
characters on tv remember that
oh and by the way when he did that thing
with the effeminate male characters he
knew that the american film industry
would never protest or complain that
that was discriminatory or anti-lgbtq
they wouldn't complain one bit heck when
was the last time you saw a chinese
villain on the big screen
and she knows by the way that key gop
establishment figures they don't lose
sleep about china's monopoly
monopolization of key industries of
course not
the only thing that motivates them is
money
and a lot of money buys china a lot of
political cover in congress
she knows all of this
because he's watched it unfold over the
past 25 years
which brings us back to the current
nightmare in ukraine
now biden could demand that john kerry
go out and say that the administration
is putting its climate change goals on
hold at least as long as china remains a
destabilizing force on the world
he could also say that as long as the
ccp is trying to
by proxy overthrow zalenski in ukraine
we're not going to abandon our oil and
gas industries
but of course the biden people would
never do something so sensible
and as a result we might as well just
have an adult beverage because we have
zero leverage
countries formally helpful to the us are
looking eastward
think about saudi arabia which just
invited xi for a visit amidst another
blunder by the united states
and the u.s is either at this point
looking at all the things that have
happened
they're either going to get stronger by
getting its own economic house in order
and begin decoupling from these despotic
regimes like china
or the world is going to get more
dangerous and more chaotic
in the meantime
the only ukraine negotiations that are
gonna happen in this scenario are the
types of negotiations that
let's say go on between a cat and a
mouse
the cat's gonna toy around with the
mouse
then pounce when the time is right
because it knows it can
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else